but only you get to decide what kind of
queen you'll be
poor queen ariana didn't have the chance
to utter a single word during tangled
but we think it's time to hear from her
she had a surprisingly eventful life
before becoming queen
and her story is an interesting take on
a classic tale this story is far older
than the brothers grimm and far
from picture perfect
it means there is more in you
[Music]
some kids just don't take an interest in
family history but in rapunzel's defense
she was kidnapped when she was a baby
and only met her parents
many years later as an adult but what
she did learn about queen ariana
she discovered her mom was a little bit
more adventurous than she once gave her
credit for
i found out that she was a little bit of
a rebel when she was my age
can you imagine her husband frederick
grew up knowing he would be king one day
and while the title is a heavy burden
there's also a kind of peace with
knowing your destiny
as faryana she struggled to find her
place in the world and her search took
on some fantastic adventures
before i met your father i was so much
like you
i had no idea what i was supposed to do
in this world she compared herself to a
young rapunzel
eager to explore the world and entangled
the series we learned she was always
eager to impress other people
sometimes a bit too eager in the movie
tangled
flynn rider described her as beloved by
the people and a woman with a great
amount of grace and wisdom
queen ariana had enough adventures to
fill up her journey and possibly another
disney movie someday
but as far as rapunzel's father king
frederick is concerned
well he's the kind of guy who prefers to
play it safe like his wife he was well
loved by his people during his rule
and in return he wants what's best for
them i know he loves me but he can be
so intense while we don't know too much
about his early life
it's safe to say it wasn't nearly as
eventful as his wife's since he didn't
know how to ride a horse
and traveling by boat wasn't easy since
he can't swim and get seasick entangled
the series
rapunzel says her father loves rules and
holds everyone around him to sky-high
standards
and he has so many rules
who does he think he is the king we both
know queen ariana and king frederick
love their daughter dearly and were
absolutely devastated when she vanished
while we aren't sure exactly what they
did to occupy the days until they were
reunited
it's not hard to imagine that running a
kingdom kept them pretty busy
prosperous kingdoms with happy citizens
don't just happen
they take a ton of work but we do know
that they never forget about rapunzel
and every day on her birthday they
released magic lanterns hoping that they
would guide her home
and in a way they did however the series
revealed that frederick's heart weighed
heavier than his wife's
due to some information he had
surrounding rapunzel's disappearance
obviously rapunzel is a star of tangled
and she generously shared much of her
screen time with the dashing rogue
flynn rider alright listen i didn't want
to have to do this but you leave me no
choice
but even though we didn't see a ton of
her parents in the first film they
actually ended up with more background
information than many other versions of
their characters
we're sure you've heard of the infamous
fairy tale collectors the brothers grimm
who had their own version of rapunzel
upon
which tangled is loosely based but they
weren't the first folks to write down
such a story
there have been many different fairy
tales over the years about maidens
trapped in tall towers
in fact princesses finding themselves in
unfortunate situations
is something of a fairytale staple the
story of rapunzel and her parents can
actually be traced back to a work
created between 977
and 1010ce the shaaname or book of kings
tells the story of princess rudabeh
whose beauty captured the heart of zal
who climbed up her tresses to meet with
her atop a high tower
rutabay's father was a man named marab
the king of kabul
although not much is known about him
besides that her mother was named cinda
who was known for her beauty and
intelligence she protested the romance
of her daughter enzal at first but she
and her husband eventually came around
there are many different versions of
rapunzel's tale
and the brothers grimm based their
famous fairy tale on personette by
charlotte rose their common de la foss
the brothers grimm didn't spend much
time on rapunzel's parents saying only
that her pregnant mother craved the
plant called rapien from a neighbor's
garden
and said if she didn't have some she
would surely perish
we know pregnancy cravings are real but
that's kind of dramatic
her husband ended up trading his child
to the witch for some of the route
because he was so desperate to feed his
pregnant wife which means she was
probably being
very dramatic after the witch takes
rapunzel she doesn't meet her parents
again
even when she's eventually freed from
the tower to be fair if my parents
traded me for some roots i wouldn't be
in a hurry to reconnect either oh
honey stop beating yourself up rapunzel
just needs some space
king frederick from tangled didn't trade
away his daughter for a salad but he did
know he was taking a massive risk by
obtaining the magical sundrop flower
in the story queen ariana fell ill when
she was pregnant with rapunzel
and would have actually perished without
any kind of intervention not only was
his wife's life at risk but so was his
child and that's enough to have a king
chasing after a legend
entangled the series we learned fredrick
was warned uprooting the flower would be
risky but he decided to go after it
anyway
warned that taking the sun drop would
reap unimaginable consequences
even though the queen was the one who
was sick frederick had to take on a
terrible burden knowing that his actions
could negatively impact his kingdom
something we saw play out entangled the
series this even caused him to doubt his
competency as a king
since he had risked his people for his
wife and child no king
would ever put the welfare of his family
before that of his country
frederick may not have had a ton of
adventures before being crowned king but
things are really eventful after that
no boats or horseback riding required of
course hindsight is 20 20. but it kind
of seems like rapunzel getting kidnapped
didn't exactly have to happen
and that either the king or mother
gothel could have prevented the events
of tangled from taking place
mother gothel is so old she actually
predates the founding of the kingdom
entirely
in order to keep herself looking young
she harnessed the power of the sundrop
flower and had to give herself a hearty
dose of magic every now and then
so she chose to keep the sun drop close
and whether by coincidence or design
ended up living a healthy distance from
the kingdom in the original brothers
grim version
her character was described as a fairy
and later on as a sorceress
but entangled she doesn't seem to have
any powers besides those she harnesses
from the flower
still she didn't even lock up the flower
or anything and of course
the one time she forgot to cover it up
people were out looking for it
the world is dark and selfish
and cruel as for the king he made it
incredibly obvious that he was seeking
it by sending out his own soldiers
instead of opting for a mercenary
whom perhaps gothel wouldn't have been
able to track back to him
maybe a smaller team or someone solo
could have prevented gothel from
learning who ended up with the flower
and there's the kind of wild option of
locking the door okay so maybe gothel
got through the lock
but really the king and queen should
have hired better security their
soldiers can track down a magical flower
on a moment's notice but they can't see
an old lady scaling the side of the
castle and climbing into the king and
queen's bedroom
in the brothers grimm story rapunzel's
mother was obsessed with a wrapping
which was replaced by the sun dropped
for tangled
singing to a wrapping would probably
just get you some strange looks
but seeing the sun drop causes it to
release pollen with anti-aging
properties when made into an infusion
it healed the queen and transferred its
magical properties to rapunzel's hair
it's clear that mother gothel queen
ariana and king frederick all lived long
lives
some more than others before rapunzel
was born these have been mostly glossed
over for now but it's possible that a
future disney movie or series will take
a deeper dive into what corona was like
long ago
could mother gothel ever have a
redemption story like maleficent or is
she simply too wicked
suddenly that's the addition to disney
plus we didn't know about
you want to go outside why rapunzel
do you appreciate that the king and
queen finally got some backstory in the
tale of rapunzel
would you like to see more of their
lives before their daughter was born let
us know what you think in the comments
below
and don't forget to click on the
subscribe button for more videos from us
at the things we'll see you next time
you